I am very much looking forward to an
Apple series called uh well I don't
actually know the title but it's
Godzilla
um so I'm just curious how many episodes
is that series
um that is 10 episodes and how many did
you direct two of them so you did the
first two yep
um I am so curious about this and I know
obviously you can only say so much but
for fans where does it take place on the
timeline in relation to the movies
you know I can't really say because
that's part of the joy of it is is
actually uh timeline is a big part of
the storytelling so just want to say
that's part of it but I can't really say
more than that sure I'll say this um
Godzilla every time he shows up on
screen is expensive
um I mean it is not cheap to put
Godzilla or any monster on screen so I
obviously Apple spends money on their
series but how much did you sort of have
to like figure out you know how many
seconds of Godzilla can we put in per
episode what's the max we can do you
know what I mean that the VFX
conversation has to be a huge part of
that series it is it's a part of
everything obviously no matter what the
scale of something you always run out of
money eventually even if it's Harry
Potter or Star Wars Star Trek whatever
you run out of money Godzilla you run
out of money
um but it's um less about counting up
shots although eventually you have to do
that
um and more just about storytelling you
know how how much was Godzilla going to
factor into the story and and he has a
very important
um role to play and and how he factors
into the series is is a big part of it
so that was the bigger driver and then
and he's not the only Titan that you're
going to meet along the way so there's
yeah there's a VFX conversation uh
constantly happening in that they're
making another Godzilla movie right now
how much did you guys sort of talk like
are you doing your own thing and then
the movies can do their own thing you
know there is some overlap though we
were not heavily involved in talking
about it with Adam Wingard or his team
um legendary is the studio for our show
as well as for the films and so they
sort of sit at the juncture there
between the two and they have a
mythology Department there which is
wonderful and so they weigh in on how
things might overlap how you know
certain creatures need to stay in one
side or the other and you know so there
is a lot of conversation about it but in
terms of the sort of how closely the
narratives over line uh overlap it's not
as involved to say an MCU kind of Disney
plus to film crossover it's less
organized than that